έχουμε μια εμπιστοσύνη και λέ ότι μπορούμε να κάνουμε έχετε ανάγκη από εμβόλεια δεν είχαν
ανάγκη τόσο πολύ απ εμβο λεως ότι δυνατότι ήταν να μπορούν να να μπουν στα
τις περιοχές και να εμπολέάστώρα εξεκίνησε το εμβολιαστικό πρόγραμ θατδίνω έναν παράδειγμα ότι αυτό που
μας έμαθε υπανδημία είναι ότι πρέπει να κινεί σε γρήγορα πρέπει να κινής έγγαιρα και
πρέπει επίσεις να μπορείς να προβλέψει το το τι μπορεί να συμβεί μέσα σε μια
κρση και επιστεύω ότι είμαστε γρήγορα τον ήταν όταν ότε αλλες χώρες εκτίζα νοσοκομία μέσα
σε μερικές εβδομάδες ενώ εμείς για να πάει ένα νοσβωμείο να κτιστεί θέλουμε χρόνια ισως
και αυτό να είναι ένα θέμα όστε έχουμε περισότερες μονάδες για τους ασθενίς πρέπει να
έχουμε πιο γρήγορα ντα ανα κλαστικά για να αντιμετωπίζουμε τα θέματα ηγείας ένα ηα έχουμε
εδώ στην κύπροκυρια κρια κίδο αυτά τα τανακλαστικά πιστεύω ότι αν συγκρίνουμε με πολλές αολές
ευρωπαϊκές χρές τα επίπεδα που τουλάχιστο βλέπω για τα θέματα αντιμετώπησης του καρκίνου στην κύπμα
είναι σε ξερετικά καλά επίπεδα δεν πρέπει να ταμιδενιζούμε όλα πάντα υπάρχει περιθοριοπελτίωσης αλλά αυτό
που είδαμε με την πανδήμια είναι ότι καμία χώρα δεν ήταν έτοιμη ήταν οι κύπρος
καμία χώρα δεν ήταν έτοιμη να αντιμετωπίσιμε ια τόσο μεγάλη κρίση και αυτό έχει τη
σημασία του για το πως δουλεύουμε στο μέλλον πρέπει να εκκοίνούμαστε πολύ πιο γρήγορα επίσης
γι αυτό τον λόγο έχουμε ισάξει με σα ένα από τους πιλώνες τις ευρωπαϊκής ανοσ
η υγίας την ηλεκτρονική για όλοι ξέρουμε τα πιστοπιτικά ψηφιακάψει πιστοπιτικά κόβιτ θεωρούμε ότι πάντα
υπήρχαν δεν υπήρχε τίποτα ταν έγινε έκλεισαντα